carry most of his life in public service
wrong segue why he fought in gentleman's
time has expired they fought in the
Vietnam War and became an anti-war
activist when he returned home in 1984
he was elected to the US Senate he
served for 28 years including his
chairman of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee
most recently he served as President
Obama Secretary of State he was a chief
negotiator of the Paris climate
agreement and the Iran nuclear deal
Kerry's new book is called every day is
extra he shares his life story from
growing up as the son of a diplomat to
becoming America's top diplomat decades
later every day is extra is published by
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS mr.
secretary good morning thank you John
with you speaking of the presidents and
presidency you had an interview on Face
the Nation to which the president
President Trump tweeted about you
possibly running for president and he
said I should only be so lucky
what's your response to that well you
know the president I I'm really not
going to get into a back and forth on
tweets you know I could give him a
nickname Agent Orange or something and I
could get back and forth but it doesn't
take you anywhere the president uses
tweets as a weapon of mass distraction
and he obviously has exposed the world
to the potential of a weapon of mass
destruction in Iran by pulling out of a
deal that everybody in the world
supports so I I'd rather stay on the
substance because he wants to distract
it and get into a fight I want to stay
on the real let's not miss his point
though because he's saying he hopes you
run because he believes he could beat
you is what he's saying what he says
that it look nothing he says can you can
believe and you always know there's a
different motive so let's not even get
into that what's important is frankly in
my book I lay out the challenge to our
country it's not it's not a policy book
that's what's important it's a story of
a life that shows how we can confront
the challenge that we face in America
today and that's that's really more
important frankly than listening to a
guy who as president United States can't
even go to the funeral of a war hero
that's the real issue before the country
what is that that's the is it immoral
the issue before the country
there's all kinds of things it's and I
write again in the book I lay out look
I'm an optimist in the book is a book of
optimism and it's a it's a it's an
insight not a policy book but an insight
to how individual citizens can bring us
back from the brink we've been through
this before
we had Richard Nixon in 1970 71 72 73
breaking the law attacking the Justice
Department enemies list we had you know
riots in the streets of America we had
people being assassinated in 68 and
before that so it was a rough time in
our country and its citizens that
brought us back from that and and this
book I think is a is a road map through
stories about people's lives and how the
Senate changed and what happened and I
think it shows people where we can make
the difference Nixon ultimately resigned
I doubt that because he broke the law
and because he was about to be impeached
well you went to high school st. Paul's
with Bob Muller who is the special
counsel you know you played sports
together you've known him you're the
same age served in Vietnam at the same
time do you believe that his report will
be taken seriously by both Republicans
and Democrats in Congress that they
would move forward in some way in terms
of wealth of office or whatever it may
be I believe that Bob Boehner is an
incredibly qualified capable straight-up
public servant he was a great leader of
the FBI unprecedented tenure he is going
to come out with whatever he comes out
with what he believes represents the
truth and then it's up to the American
citizen not Democrats and Republicans
but the American citizens to decide how
they respond to that and we're lucky to
have somebody as qualified as Bob Mahler
to take on this task you took all you
talked a lot about the truth in your
book may I mention it every day is extra
please hold it up because you're right
it's more than just policy there is some
policy but it's very antidotal you said
you learn that when you push for the
truth people were invested in lies
retaliate do you think that's happening
today number one and you always say but
the truth is worth fighting for
well it is happening today of course
it's happening today
unfortunately the president tax people
who tell the truth in fact we have a
party that regrettably has turned its
back to some degree on the truth and I
think it's very very regrettable meaning
the Republican Party the Republican
Party and the Senate particularly but
also in the house the truth has less
currency than it should have in a
democracy of our quality truth is the
essence and you have baseline of facts
you need to be able to know what the
facts are we've we've entered a new
period of life I mean I saw it in my
campaign
Nora you remember the attacks against me
were sort of the beginning of
alternative facts and now we see this on
a regular basis facts don't
apparently matter to some people I
believe they matter to the American
people John McCain believed they both
mattered the American people John was
always ready to tell the truth and I
think the last days have been a reminder
of that value that is so important to
America and I write about I have old
chapter in the book yeah about John
McCain and our journey together he said
that you flirted but you never dated
that at one point you all considered
running together that you thought we had
a couple of very serious conversations
about it and it obviously didn't happen
John evidently liked the idea because he
then thought about it with respect to
Joe Lieberman in the next round but
again the same kind of difficulties that
we confronted apparently rose and it
wasn't doable but the spirit was there
and what's important is John stood up
for the truth during that campaign too
he and we you know again when John was
attacked in South Carolina I write about
this in the book you know Chuck Hagel
Republican John Kerry Chuck rod Bob
Kerry the Vietnam veterans came together
to defend John McCain against these
these attacks which were made up and
without facts so the book is a defense
of our country but it's done I think in
a way that's that I hope is very
personal first of all it's personal it
you know I'm just candid as I can be
above my life
can we talk about yeah we talk about
North Korea because as you know that is
probably one of them that is considered
by our intelligence experts the greatest
national security threat facing
country right now what's wrong with
talking with Kim jong-un and what the
president meeting with him absolutely
nothing wrong I'm a great believer in
reaching out and engaging in talking but
you have to do so with a strategy you
have to do so based on facts and you
have to not raise expectations on
yourself in a way that defeats your goal
what President Trump did was basically
give Kim jong-un the meeting that he and
his father and his grandfather always
wanted with the person testing with
without getting without getting the kind
of intrusive inspection or
accountability that you need for his
weapons and that still hasn't happened
but Donald Trump stood up in Singapore
and said oh it's all good now the issues
got away there's no nuclear threat when
in fact our intelligence community is
saying there's a greater threat today
than there was before he had his meeting
but that's just one gamut okay it
doesn't work now they're back to where
they were but at least he got the
missile testing stopped he got a meeting
of the two countries that was a that was
some progress he got everything on track
of the loser could be happening right
now as a matter of common sense for Kim
jong-un if he were missile testing now
he would invite or he knows that but
he's reached the level in his weaponry
that the threat has grown and he is not
denuclearizing denuclearization was the
goal at Donald Trump announced the
denuclearization but there's been not
only no denuclearization there's not
even a common understanding of what it
means now in in in my book I to get
people you know dragged into some long
policy discussion but I show how on a
number of different issues the way we
did the Paris Accords where we are now
on climate change climate change is an
existential threat to our nation's are
you thinking about running into we're
not doing no I I've said again and again
and I it's hard to get away from that
but I mean I doubt very much I'll be
running for office again but but I'll
say this that no one should be focused
on 2020 right now we should be focused
on 2018 because the magic number for
America to think about is 50 4.2
that was the number of eligible voters
that turned out to vote with the
presidency in 2016 when I ran in no 4 it
was 60.4% turned out when Obama was
elected no 8 it was 62.5 what we what we
need people to engage and make a
difference and in 2018 we have a chance
to have a course correction and I think
in my book I lay out the ways that
people can really engage and do that
thank you we are out of time but
secretary Kerry thank you my pleasure to
be with you to talk about